[موسيقى]
حذر عقائد القياده الوصله الامريكيه
لجنرال مايكل كوريلا من توفر ظروفي تفاقم
الصرع في الضفه الغربيه ولما حاير امكانيه
اندلاعب ما سماه صراعا كبيرا هناك في اي
لحظه وتاتي هذه التحذيرات على وقع
اقتحامات اسرائيليه يوميه للضفه الغربيه
اسقطت منذ مطلع العام 88 شهيدا فلسطينيا
بينهم 17 طفلا بحسب وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ونناقشه في
ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله صدور تصريحات بهذه
الخطوره عن مسؤول عسكري امريكي بهذا
المستوى وما واجهت هذه التصريحات بالنظر
الى المعطيات على الارض واي خيارات وفق
هذه التحذيرات يمكن ان تلجا الي حكومه
نتنياهو بالنظر الى ازماتها المتعدده في
الداخل الاسرائيلي وما خيارات الفلسطينيين
لمواجهه ذلك
وما هي الخطوات التي يمكن ان تتخذها
واشنطن على ضوء تحذيرها من احتمال انفجار
الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وما مدى
قدره واشنطن على احتواء هذا الامر
[موسيقى]
خلال جلسه استماع امام لجنه الدفاع في
الكونغرس الامريكيه اكد قائد الوسطى
الامريكيه الجنرال مايكل كوريلا اتفاقه مع
تصريحات للعهد الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني راى فيها ان المنطقه تمر حاليا
باخطر اوقاتها واضاف الجذر الكورولا ان
ظروفها تفاقم الصراع في الضفه الغربيه
متوفره حاليا ولما الى احتمال وقوع ما
سماه صراعا كبيرا بالضفه الغربيه
ونحن نراقب الوضع عن كثب نعتقد ان الظروف
موجوده والفتيل والشراره موجودان ايضا ولا
نعرف ما الذي يمكن ان يتطلبه الامر حتى
تؤدي الشراره الى صراع اكبر في الضفه
الغربيه
هذه التحذيرات من قائد القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه تاتي على خلفيه اقتحامات
اسرائيليه يوميه لضف لمدن الضفه الغربيه
راح ضحيتها منذ مطلع العام الحالي ثمانيه
وثمانون شهيدا فلسطينيا بينهم سبعه عشر
طفلا وفق احصاءات وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
اخر هؤلاء الشهداء شيعتهم جنين يوم الخميس
ومن بينهم قائدان عسكريان في حركه حماس
والجهاد الاسلامي
اغتالتهما وحده اسرائيليه خاصه بزعم
انتاجهما عبوات ناسفه واطلاقهم النار على
جنود الاحتلال في الاشهر الماضيه قد
اندلعت خلال العمليه مواجهات مسلحه مع
فلسطينيين اصيب خلالها اكثر من ثلاثه
وعشرين فلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع
سنناقشه على جزئين الجزء الاول لينضم
الينا من تل ابيب مائيهر
جيف الدينفر الباحث والمحلل السياسي
الاسرائيلي سيد جافي دليفري
بالنظر الى هذه التصريحات من قائد القياده
الوسطى الامريكيه ان الظروف مهيئه هذه
تصريحات لاندلاع الصراع في الضفه الغربيه
هذه تصريحات على خلفيه اقتحامات شبه يوميه
من الجانب الاسرائيلي للضفه الغربيه ما
الذي يريد ان يحققه الجانب الاسرائيلي
بتكرار مثل هذه الاقتحامات التي في
النهايه قد تؤدي الى اندلاع صراع كبير في
المنطقه
ان هدف هذه الهجمات
هي تحييد البنى البنيه التحتيه للارهابيين
في الضفه الغربيه طبعا انا لا اقول ان كل
ارهابيين هم ارهابيين لا سمح الله لكن
هناك فعلا بعض المنظمات الارهابيه في
الظفره الغربيه قامت بتنفيذه هجمات ضد
مواطنين دوله اسرائيل وان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بمهاجمه في الضفه الغربيه
يريدوا منعهم منعهم التنفيذه
عمليات ارهابيه في المستقبل ضد المواطنين
الاسرائيليين والواقع والواقع سيد ماهر ان
الهجمات الاسرائيليه مستمره وايضا
العمليات التي يقوم بها المواطنون
الفلسطينيون بشكل فردي مستمر لم تتوقف لا
هذه العمليات ولا الاقتحامات كيف تنظرون
اذا الى دلاله تصريحات المسؤول الامريكيه
العسكري في هذا الشان هنالك خشيه من
اندلاع صراع في الضفه الغربيه بسبب
الاوضاع هذه
اعتقد انه محق بكلامي هذا ومحق في قلقه
اولا لدينا شهر رمضان المبارك حيث تزداد
التوترات في هذه المنطقه بين الاسرائيليين
وفلسطينيين فهذه اوقات حساسه جدا ثم علينا
ولو تعرفونه ومشاهديكم يعرفون هناك الكثير
من عدم الراحه والتراب في اسرائيل هناك
التظاهرات غير مسبوقه كما انك الزياده
ان محمود العباسي يفقدون وصلت يفقدون
شعبيتهم في الضفه الغربيه ومن جانب الاخر
لدينا حكومه هي اكثر حكومه عنصريه في
تاريخ اسرائيل لدى السيد ابن غفير الذي
كان عضوا في منظمه
عصريه وقد حك عليه
ثمان مرات من قبل المحاكم الاسرائيليه كما
اننا زياده في لجمات المتطرفين اليهود ضد
العرب
لا اريد ان نعمم كل ما تقوم به الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لكن اعتقد ان السيد بن غفير
لو نظرنا سجلي في السابق
فهو شخص
كان لديه النظره الثاقبه
والشخص لا يتحمل مسؤوليه ولا يبالي فهو
كسب شعبياته عن طريق العنصريه وعنده خلق
النزاعات وهو نشاهد كيف انه ذهب الى مسجد
الاقصى يعني
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ماذا
سيستفيد اذا انفجرت الاوضاع في الضفه
الغربيه يعني ما هو استناره اليوم التالي
سيكون الوضع او الايام القادمه تكون حساسه
جدا
فهناك ممثلين من في مصر ومصريين وسلطه
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
والاردن سيجتمعون لايجاد الطريق لتهدئه
الاوضاع نامل ذلك وننتظر نراه شكرا جزيلا
لك من تل
ابيبرا الباحث المحلله
ونرحب اذا بضيفينا من واشنطن الدكتور
بريتسبرون المدير السابق للتعاون الانخراط
الدوري لحل الازمات في البيت الابيض خلال
اداره الرئيس الاسبق باراك اوباما ونرحب
كذلك من الخليل بالسيد عادل شديد الباحث
المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي وهنا اريد ان
افهم من ضيفنا من واشنطن
دلالات ادلى به كوريلا قائد القياده
الوسطى الامريكيه بشان احتمال تفجر
الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه في اي لحظه وان
الشراره يمكن ان تاتي في اي لحظه ما
المعطيات التي يستند اليها في ذلك
اعتقد اولا انه ادراك لما هو واضح بان
الوضع كان يتفاقم ويتدهور على مدى الاشهر
الماضيه وهذا تحذير اعتقد انه تحذير
لكل من القاده الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
باننا يجب ان نرى مزيدا من الجهود لتخفيف
حده التوتر وان عليهم ان يلتزموا الحذر
ولا نستطيع ان نتحمل ايه خطوات خاطئه او
تصريحات خاطئه او اي اعمال استفزازيه كما
انه ايضا مؤشر من ان الولايات المتحده
تريد ان تقول باننا مستعدون لاتخاذ خطوات
اضافيه ربما مثل فرض الضغوط على كلا
الطرفين لتفادي هذا الانفجار
لتصبح الامور بمثابه ازمه متفاقمه كامله
سناتي الى الخطوات الامريكيه لاحقا لكن
هذا التصريح طبعا
لم يكتفي فيه كوريلا بمساله الضفه الغربيه
وتحدث ايضا عن المنطقه باكملها وان الثراء
يمكن ان يكون كبيرا وانه يتفق مع الملك
عبد الله العهد الاردني بان المنطقه في
وضع خطير للغايه ثم تحدث عن ان الضفه يمكن
ان تاتي منها الشراره هل هنالك خشيه
امريكيه حقيقيه فعلا من صراع كبير في
المنطقه منطقه الشرق الاوسط
من الواضح ان امامنا عدد من العوامل التي
تفعل فعلها الان وهي سوف تساهم
بخلق وضع ربما يبدا
حاله من النزاع والشرار الصغيره التي تخرج
عن نطاق السيطره بسرعه وهذا ما يقلق
الولايات المتحده طبعا هذا امر غير معهود
لا ترى مثل هذه التحذيرات المباشره من
مسؤولين امريكيين وبالتاكيد من مسؤولين
عسكريين ما لم يكن الكلام مستند الى
شايفهم يتابعون الاوضاع في المنطقه من
وجهه نظر دبلوماسيه
وامنيه كذلك وسبب الذي
جعلنا نسمع هذه التصريحات من الجنرال هي
بمثابه تحذير
ولفت انتباه الى ان يلتزمت جميع الحذر وان
يتخذ الجميع كل الخطوات المناسبه للتعامل
مع بواعثي القلق هذه
سيد عادل شديد من الخليل كيف تنظر الى هذه
التصريحات من المسؤول الامريكيه من مايكل
كوريلا قائد القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
تحياتي لك
ولضيفك وللمشاهدين لا شك انها تعكس
قراءه
للمعطيات والمعلومات والعناصر
الميدانيه لا شك انه المنطقه دخلت في
مرحله توتر منذ فتره واعتقد انه السبب
واضح ولا احد يختلف على ذلك اولا نهايه
عمليه اوستو والمفاوضات لبن انها وصلت الى
طريق مسدود وقناعه فلسطينيه انه اتت
بخسائر اكثر بكثير مما حققته من نتائج
وانجازات للفلسطينيين ثم
التطورات الاخيره في اسرائيل سواء صعود
اليمين الديني الفاشي او
التطورات الداخليه الازمات الداخليه وكلها
تلقي بظلالها على الحاله الفلسطينيه بشكل
عام بالتالي نحن مقبلين على مرحله بتاكيد
سنشهد فيها تصاعد
للاش الامني اللي بدم منذ اكثر من من سنه
وتصاعد ولكن واضح انه هاي الجهود
الامريكيه والاقليميه تريد الزام
الفلسطينيين بان يبقوا حراس
حراس امن وان يقدمه هدوء مجاني اعتقد انه
القناعه الفلسطينيه
الاخره بالازدياد والمثاني يوما عن يوم
انه كان في خطا فلسطيني كبير حين قبل ان
يكون الفلسطيني شريك بالتهدئه
الدور اللي قام فيه الفلسطيني بالتهدئه
وخلق حاله استقرار اعتقادا منه انه من
الممكن ان يشكل
بوابه ومدخل وممر للوصول الى مفاوضات
سياسيه ثبت انه اتى بنتائج عكسيه انه
اسرائيل
هذا الاستقرار بالهدوء من الجانب
الفلسطيني وكانه
هذه القناه الفلسطينيه بان اوسلو انتهت
عبر انا مثلا نائب قائد اركان كتائب عز
القسام مروان عيسى وقرن المستقبل والايام
القادمه حبله بالاحداث هل هذه القناعه
قناعه فلسطينيه عامه وبالتالي ما نتوقعه
من الجانب الفلسطيني هو فعل وليس رد فعل
للاقتحامات الاسرائيليه ام انه قناعه بعض
الفصائل الفلسطينيه فقط
لا هو اصلا الذي يدير الحاله الاشتباك منذ
اكثر من عام هي عمليات بمعظمها تجاوزت
الفصائل بمعنى انه اليوم كل المجتمع كل
راي العام الفلسطيني متى مقتنع ومجمع على
ان اوسلو انتهت وفشلت ولكن قراءه ما بعد
الفشل وكيفيه المواجهه هنالك نقاش فلسطيني
داخلي ولكن اليوم وفق كل الاستطلاعات وفي
كل الدراسات والابحاث وفق ما نتابع
ميدانيا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بعد
العمليات واضح انه الاغلبيه الساحقه من
المجتمع الفلسطيني ورائي العام الفلسطيني
باتت اليوم تؤيد وبقوه عوده العمل المسلح
ضد اسرائيل والمقاومه بكافه اشكالها وخاصه
انه اسرائيل لم تستمر فقط في مشروع تدمير
اركان او اسس عمليه السلام اللي ممكن ان
تؤدي الى حصول الفلسطينيين على الاقل على
الحد الادنى من حقوقهم الشرعيه لكنها
تمادت بكثير ثم
لن تعد فقط اسرائيل تتصرف
وكانها بالموقع المنتصر لا بل تريد تحقيق
هزيمه فلسطينيه واضحه اليوم النقاش
الاسرائيلي مبني على فرضيه واضحه انه
الفلسطينيين تنازلوا وهم افضل من حالهم
اليوم على 78% من مساحه فلسطين التاريخيه
اليوم بظل الوضع الحالي استمرار للضغط
الاسرائيلي والتنصل من كل التزامات
اسرائيل من الممكن ان يقود الى ان يرفع
الفلسطيني الراي البيضاء هذا الواقع خلق
حاله نقاش عام
بالاوساط الفلسطينيه ادى الى هاي الخلاصه
انه اسرائيل لا يمكن ان تفهم سوى لغه
المقاومه والكفاح
بكل اشكاله وبما في اولا الكفاح المسلح
طالما نلاحظ هذا الاحتضان الفلسطيني
الكبير الى العمليات لمنفذي العمليات
اليوم على الاقل هنالك اكثر من حالي كان
تسجيل اسماء مواليد جدد الاسماء فدائيين
نفذوا عمليات نوعيه ضد اسرائيل بالفتره
الماضيه بكل الاحوال اليوم الشارع
الفلسطيني مجمع على فشل عمليه اوسلو ولكن
اكثريته الساحقه باتت تجمع على الكفاح
المسلح الان ما يراد من هذه الاجتماعات هو
حصر الموضوع النقاش الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
وكانه في النقاش الامني وكان الازمي
بالعمليات الفلسطينيه وليس بالاحتلال
واجراءات وسياساتها ومساكيات وعمليات
القتلان وتوغل التي يمارسها بالامس حول
المقاربه الامريكيه سؤال حول المقاربه
الامريكيه واعود الى الدكتور
المدير السابق للتعاون والاخيرات الدولي
لحل الازمات في البيت الابيض خلال فتره
براك اوباما المقاربه الامريكيه في عقود
ماضيه كانت نحو الوصول لاتفاق سلام
ثم في عهد الرئيس بايدن وقبله الرئيس
اوباما هذا الامر تلاشى ثم عاد رئيس بايدن
الرئيس ترامب هذا الامر تلاشى والان لا
حديث عن سلام
فما الذي يريد ان يحققه الامريكيون هل
يمكن الابقاء على الواضع تحت السيطره دون
اي افق للسلام
للاسف نعم هذا هو وضعنا الان
لا يوجد اي اهتمام هنا في واشنطن حاليا
للاستثمار في ايه عمل سلام انا اتذكر
عندما كنت اخدم في البيت الابيض ايامه ما
عندما كان وزير الخارجيه جونكري يقوم
برحلاته الدبلوماسيه المكوكيه بيزوروا
المسؤولين الفلسطينية والاسرائيليين بحثا
عن ارضيه مشتركه وعن صفقه في الحقيقه تلك
كانت
اخرت جهود الحقيقيه التي بذلتها الولايات
المتحده للاسف انتهت من دون فشل هنا في
الولايات المتحده
الان الكل يتحدث عن تلك المحاوله بشيء من
التحوط الكل يقول اذا ما قمت بايه جهد
لاحلال السلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين
تنتهي بالاحباط وبالشعور بالاحباط وهي اذا
لا معنى لها وما ولا
المقاطعه وهنا نتوقف عند مره اخرى عند
تصريحات الجنرى لو تسمح لي هنالك قلق من
انفجار الاوضاع ما الذي ستفعله واشنطن كي
لا تنفجر مشغوله بالملفات كبيره حرب
اوكرانيا
المواجهه مع الصين ولا تريد في هذه
المنطقه لا حربا في الضفه ولا صراعا في
الضفه ولا حربا اقليميه فما الذي ستفعله
واشنطن لابقاء الهدوء في هذه المنطقه من
العالم
يمكن ان اقول ان الوقت حاليا هو وقت غير
مناسب تماما
لاندلاعي ازمه شامله في الشرق الاوسط
وسنرى جهودا يبذلها الوزير لينكن والرئيس
بايدن في محاوله لتفادي ذلك السيناريو لكن
الامور التي رايناها على مدى العامين
الماضيين من رئاسه بايدن هي بعض المحاولات
لتعل الازمات فقط نحافظ على درجه من
الهدوء بحيث لا تغلي وتنقلب الى انفجار
فقط وهل هذا ممكن فيه الكفايه لابطال
تسيطر وهذا ما نراه الان هل هذا ممكن يعني
ابقاء الوضع تحت السيطره بهذه المقاربه هل
هذا ممكن استاذ عادل الشديد على الاقل هل
هو ممكن فلسطينيا تحدثت عن انه هنالك
قناعه الان بانه انتهت وانه لابد من
الكفاح المسلح هل هنالك افق زمني بعيد
المدى لهذا الكفاح المسلح ام اننا نتحدث
عن بالفعل بدء عمليه الكفاح عن طريق
العمليات واخرها العمليه التي تبنتها حماس
في تل ابيب
يعني بالقراءه الدقيقه للواقع الفلسطيني
نصل الى خلاصه انه كل
المؤشرات تشير انه المنطقه ذاهبه باتجاه
التصعيد سواء بفعل ما تحدثنا عنه نهايه
عمليه اوبو وتحويلها الى داله خدمه
اسرائيل واحكام سيطرتها على الشعب
الفلسطيني والجغرافيا والموارد وما شابه
ثم هذا التطرف الكبير في اسرائيل ولكن
هنالك ايضا متغيرات فلسطينيه داخليه تفرض
باتجاه الذهاب باتجاه الكفاح وتجدد
المقاومه وخاصه النقاش الذي يغلي داخل
اوساط الكثير من قواعد حركات فاتح وخاصه
بالنقاش لمرحله ما بعد الرئيس محمود عباس
اليوم
النقاش الداخلي الفلسطيني ايضا يراد اعاده
تشكيل حركه فتح كحركه تحرر وطني كح ثوريه
اغلبيه
قواعد حركه فتح قد يكون هنالك من يختلف مع
مع مع هذا التوجه ولكن هنالك نقاش يغلي
داخل اروقه وصفوف وقواعد حركه فتح بضروره
عوده حركه فتح الى مشروع الاصلي لكي تكون
حركه تحرر لا ان تكون حزب سلطه تدافع عن
عن سلطه باتت واقع وتكيفت تحت ظل الاحتلال
الشامل مشروع السلطه اتى كنواه لدوله نقيض
للاحتلال شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ عادل شديد
الباحث المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي من
الخليل ونشكر ضيفنا من واشنطن الدكتور
بريتش المدير السابق للتعاون والانخراط
الدولي لحل الازمات في البيت الابيض في
فتره حكم باراك اوباما
وصلنا لنهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر دمتم في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]